au voleur au voleur à la salsa au
meurtrier justice le juge niel
je suis perdu je suis apte à signer on
m'a coupé la gorge
on m'a dérobé mon amour qui peut s'être
qu'est-il devenu
où est-il où se cachent nil que ferais
je pour le trouver ou courir ou ne pas
courir
n'est-il point le net ils pointent ici
qui s arrête à moi mon amour qu aucun
témoin mon esprit est troublée et
j'ignore où je suis qui je suis ce que
je fais hélas
mon pauvre mou mon pauvre amour mon cher
ami
on va priver de toi puisque tu mets
enlevé g j'ai perdu mon support la
consolation 20 juin tout est fini pour
moi et je n'ai plus que faire au monde
sans toi il m'est impossible de vivre
sans effet je n'en suis plus je me meurs
je suis morte je suis hanté les nuits à
toute personne qui va ils meurent et
susciter me rends dans mon cher amour ou
en apprenant qu'il apprit que des loupes
sous les personnes il faut
qui que ce soit qui ait fait le coup
qu'avec beaucoup de soin on était payé
leur et on a choisi justement le temps
que je parlais à mon traître deux fils
sortant je veux aller quérir la justice
et faire donner la question a toute ma
maison avalées à ces reventes à fille à
fils et à moi aussi que de gens
rassemblés
je ne jette mais regarde sur personne tu
ne me donnes des soupçons et tout me
semble être mon voleur et de quoi est ce
qu'on parle là de celui qui m'a dérobé
quel bruit fait temps là où est-ce qu'on
voleur qu'il y ait que de grâce si l'on
sait des nouvelles de mon voleur je suis
flic normandise n'est-il point caché là
parmi vous il me regarde tous et se met
à rire
vous verrez qu'ils on part sans doute au
bol que l'on a fait allons vite des
commissaires des archers des juges des
prébendes hygen dépendance et des
bourreaux je veux faire pendant tout le
monde mais si je ne retombe dans l'amour
je vais prendre et moi même après